welcome back to Long crime daily we move
over to Los Angeles where that 70 show
actor Danny Masterson is on trial for
rape charges the allegations come from
three different women claiming that
Masterson raped them between 2001 and
2003 and this week they shared their
stories on the stand on Wednesday
morning one accuser identified as n
trout said leaving Scientology made her
realize she was a victim to Masterson
while she was still in the community
saying quote I did not want to think of
someone in the church that I was
friendly with as a rapist trout said the
2003 assault happened after a Masterson
reportedly forced her to drink wine that
caused her to feel quote heavy in body
like a numbness during that time trout
thought she was on a tour of Masters in
Hollywood Hills home but that's just one
of many accusations connected to the
Church of Scientology law and crimes own
Angela Levy took a closer look at recent
social media outcry from outspoken
mattress and ex-scientologist Leah
Remini on lawn crimes podcasts sidebar
with journalist Tony Ortega
Leah Remini calls these women credible
who've accused any Masterson of rape she
said that they reported their rapes to
Scientology and to the top ethics
officials in Scientology and a few
trusted friends so she's saying these
claims are corroborated and that's Now
we move to tweet Point number 32 where
Remini says Scientology has obstructed
Justice in covering up Danny's crimes
and his case is not the only time
they've done this Scientology has
covered up at least hundreds of similar
crimes involving sexual violence so
Scientology is very good at intimidating
people and yes that includes law
enforcement are they ready for that to
be the rest of their career because
that's what it's going to be years and
years of vicious fights and courts and I
think the government sometimes just
doesn't have the stomach for it
Terry it appears the Church of
Scientology allegedly altered these
women's mindset being a part of this a
group uh and saying whether it is or
isn't rape but could that inconsistency
in the beginning of their story cause
Reasonable Doubt in the trial
could you know the question of consent
is certainly going to play a huge role
in this case if someone consents but
they thought they had no other choice
was that really consent what I will say
is that under California law rape is
defined as using Force threats or fraud
and as a means of having that
non-conceptual intercourse with another
person and that's a serious crime you
know he could be punished up to eight
years and under Megan's Law he's going
to have to register as a lifetime sex
offender so that question of consent is
extremely critical here yeah now Terry
in Weinstein and Cosby we saw the
prosecution have to address the myths of
when and why people don't report do you
get the sense of prosecution explaining
that well enough to the jury in the
context of this insular group the Church
of Scientology
you know the prosecutor has to make sure
they explain that explicitly there is
definitely going to be someone on that
jury who doesn't understand that people
think okay something happened to you why
didn't you report it immediately it is a
very important concept and they're going
to have to make sure that each and every
one of those jurors understands that
people don't report for a number of
reasons it doesn't mean that the crime
did not occur yeah we'll see if that
point gets driven home in this case well
moving on to the next story where the
capitol police officers who were
supposed to be watching Nancy Pelosi's
San Francisco home on Friday when her
husband was attacked were not actually
monitoring the cameras The Washington
Post reports that Capital police first
installed surveillance cameras around
the Pelosi home more than eight years
ago but an officer on duty overnight did
not realize something was wrong until
San Francisco police showed up at the
scene David de babe is now facing both
federal and state charges he's accused
breaking into the home and attacking 82
year old Paul Pelosi with a hammer
debate pled not guilty to State charges
on Tuesday Paul Pelosi is recovering
from his injuries which include a skull
fracture from the attack
starting in August lawmakers were given
up to ten thousand dollars each to set
up security systems at their home